my compadre from the NFL Network is
brian balding or how are you doing Baldy
well hello rich I'm doing great I'm I'm
right where I spend a whole lot of my
time right here in this film room and
NFL Films and I'm having a great
afternoon here rich said that's that's
where you do these is you're you go into
the the be the sable Mahal down there in
southern New Jersey and and that's where
how do you choose what what you're
breaking down Baldy you know I don't
have any sort you know sometimes you
just want to see like you know how did
Philip Lindsay do that against
Pittsburgh's defense on sunny you want
to go back and watch him run the ball
and how they ran it so I may have some
preconceived things but I just put games
on I start watching and I just wait for
things to jump out at me
it could be play calls it could be
designed it could be just you know some
awful tackling and that Eagles and
Giants game I mean it could be anything
and then whatever sort of hits me I just
sort of start posting and let the fancy
kind of some of the things that they
might have missed watching the game well
I love it man you're doing a great job
of it so let's let's bite on that one
with Philip Lindsay and and and in the
same vein it seems like James Connor
isn't as effective the last couple of
weeks what have you seen on film in
regards to both of those running backs
well Phillip Lindsey he might be the
fastest back in the league rich I mean
you constantly see defensive backs and
linebackers takes the wrong angle and he
just runs right by him you know only the
young back in Green Bay right now Aaron
Jones is averaging more yards per carry
then Phillip Lindsay's averaging five
point eight yards of carry a yard more
than say Quan so I think if a team could
come out of this pack here it could be
Denver right now with the two wins
they've just posted back-to-back here
against the Chargers and Steelers and
Lindsay's a big part of it in for James
Connor they kind of went away from him
I'm not sure why Pittsburgh and a game
that was 1717 and knotted up for long
stretches went away from James Connor
and decided to throw it 56 times I think
you know guys like Connor he has shown
you all year that you got to keep
feeding him and the more touches he gets
the more big plays you're going to get
out of them and so at the end of the
game Big Ben
created a bit of a stir by discussing
how the Interceptor got blocked into a
route that Antonio Brown should have
been running flat as opposed to drifting
in the end zone what does the eye in the
sky tell you on that final play well
it's almost like the Tim Tebow jump pass
I mean you know it looked like there was
a little miscommunication between him
and Connor on the ball fake and then you
know Antonio Brown is going vertical and
the defender Roby got underneath it I
don't know if if Shelby Harris if he
doesn't intercept the ball if the ball
isn't going to be intercepted by Roby
and so you know it's kind of a peculiar
play to be honest with you in that spot
you're throwing the ball into a heavy
traffic like that
and so I mean sure there's frustration
when the game ends on that type of a
play in the final minute but it wasn't
really well executed but I'm balding her
here on the Rich Eisen show in the Honda
inside a report which quarterback have
you seen on film that's executing at the
highest level well knows nobody like to
agrees right now right i mean it's it's
just everything i mean how do you throw
four touchdown passes on thanksgiving
while we're all enjoying our seconds the
players that were drafted it's just rich
honestly i want to see you out there
with your five five nine forty times
that's nice catch a touchdown pass rich
i mean cameraman i mean let's have a
raffle who can catch drew brees next
touchdown pass because they're all open
and they're all making great plays dan
Arnold you know Tommy Lee Lewis it
doesn't matter who their name is right
now done and as you point out he's just
he's just executing it's such an insane
level I mean there's there's no doubt
about it so where do you stand on the
scheme argument regards to the Green Bay
Packers who are have the same record as
Baker Mayfield's Browns right now at
four six and one where do you stand on
the offense and McCarthy and Aaron
Rodgers and the way it's being executed
right now it looks awfully stale rich it
just looks like we've been watching this
same movie over and over again yet sent
three receivers out let them go try to
win one-on-ones let Aaron Rodgers and
that golden right arm of his try to go
fit the ball into some place and at
times you know he's just dropped that
perfect and then at other times you know
nobody's really getting open and
the past protection starting to break
down and Aaron's moving it's just the
offense just doesn't have a rhythm to it
when you watch the tight end you think
that Jimmy Graham by this point would be
a big part of it and he's still part of
this offense and so there just lacks any
kind of a rhythm to what they do right
now and what about the Patriots offense
that seems to be more more reliant on
Sony Michelle to succeed what do you
think here I wonder sometimes rich why
all teams don't have a fullback that
James Devlin I mean when they go in that
- but you know they ran the ball 36
times on Sunday rich against your Jets
the the only negative run they had the
whole day was on Tom Brady's finer nail
down in the victory formation that
fullback keeps the line of scrimmage
clean and I don't care if Leonard
Williams penetrates or Jamal Adams
penetrates or whoever was there at the
line of scrimmage he cleans it up in
Saudi Michelle James white cordarrelle
Patterson or running the ball and yes
Michelle had a great day a great
afternoon and they just have an undying
commitment to the run and it's one of
the reasons why they're always
successful in December and get to
January aren't a factor and it's
interesting brian balding here in the
Honda inside a report Mike Zimmer who's
always honest that's one of the many
reasons why he's so terrific on a
conference call today with the Vikings
paying a visit to cordarrelle Patterson
former viking quote quite honestly
they're using him way better than we did
is what he said well I mean we were
never really very surprised by what the
Patriots do but what you know I mean
they have all these injuries that
running back and they need a running
back and Sony Michele is on the shelf
for a little while
well Kordell paracin is six foot to 230
pounds of number one draft pick with
return ability all that stuff that we
saw and they said well let's make him an
a tailback and he was really good at it
and still is good at it so they just
constantly find things that players can
do and then they kind of test it they
put them in the laboratory and they try
it out during practice and then they go
with it and it's a great set and he's
been a real addition to that team in in
their commitment to the run game
Brian balding her here on the Honda
inside a report I loved your particular
ball D breakdown on Quintin Nelson
couple weeks ago when he just
absolu is that against the Jaguars was
that what that was well if every week
rich young moments in the Colts the
argument rich you know going back to you
know either at the draft in Dallas and
can you take your guard at number six
he's the best player in that draft and I
think he's I mean there's sake want
there's all these great rookies it's a
great class
but this Quintin Nelson has changed the
entire culture in Indianapolis they went
six weeks without giving up a sack to
engine luck they're a hot team they've
won five in a row they'll take anybody
on they go down to Houston this week
it's a great matchup against a good
defensive line but this guy's attitude
first of all he's great at what he does
he's just an earthmover he's just a John
Deere tractor in a football uniform but
then he runs around the field like he's
got a third lung and he's there at the
end of every play to pick up his running
back protect his quarterback go grab his
receiver off the field he's just changed
he's made Anthony Costanzo and Ryan
Kelly better at center and at left
tackle right now well it certainly is
adding up to wins there's no doubt about
it so let's let's start brass taxing in
here based on the film that you've seen
based on your analysis you've got a
choice for Defensive Player of the Year
obviously you've got Aaron Donald and
Khalil Mac and JJ Watt you can maybe
even throw Darius Leonard who we had on
yesterday's show from the Colts in that
mix who do you choose - that
conversation rich I mean I bears are a
hot team obviously they go to New York
this week he's got three defensive
touchdowns you know and none bigger than
the one last week that puts these games
on ice but I hardly know and what he's
doing the only team that has been
successful in the last two months to
keep him off the quarterback was the New
Orleans Saints and if you talk to the
offensive line coach Dan roster that
week they spent hours after midnight
designing schemes so that he never was
singled up one time the whole day by
formation by personnel groupings and
they did a great job limiting him but
it'd be hard right now to say that Aaron
Donald threw you know 12 weeks isn't the
Defensive Player of the Year and then in
terms of the schemes that you've seen
and you know that the how it all is
borne out in meeting rooms throughout
the week and then unveiling them at the
proper time pushing the right buttons
who's your coach of the year but I tell
you rich I've been watching football as
long as you and as long as anybody I've
never seen a Bears offense that looks
like this ever Wow
and they are just an exciting group and
every guys that they brought in from
trey Burton to Allen Robinson Taylor
Gabriel to Anthony Miller out of to
Memphis I mean they have all hit on
every one of those players and that
offense right now is a handful for
anybody so well Sean Payton in Sean
McVeigh and Andy Reid all those guys are
great candidates too right now to see
what Matt Negi is doing they've done it
without their starting quarterback
they've done it without Kelly oh Mack
they've overcome they've done it without
Kyle long and they keep winning and
finding new ways to win
right now it'd be hard for me to go
against Matt Negi and what he's doing do
you think the Bears win a playoff game
Brian yeah I do i I don't know you know
we got to see how it plays out obviously
short with us if they're on the road or
at home but well they'll be at home I
think they're gonna be at home for the
first one though Brian I think you could
sit there and say it's either it could
be against Seattle could be against
Minnesota could be against it could be
against Carolina I mean you have no idea
could be against Dallas or Washington
you have no Philly I mean there's a
whole variety of teams that could walk
in there first Saturday or Sunday of
January there's no question and so the
only you know home game that they have
lost this year was the New England
Patriots when they put up 31 yeah 31
points I mean I think it's going to be a
tough assignment for any team to go into
Soldier Field as crazy as that crowd is
right now the field will be just
god-awful at that point in January you
might as well play it you know on a
Sandlot because that's what it's going
to look like and that defense in what
Vic Fangio was doing with all the pieces
that he has in that offense I think
they're gonna win a playoff game for
sure
baldie
chat and I really I really love the to
your your Twitter baldie breakdowns man
it's a lot much everyone should check it
out at ball the NFL that's brian balding
or calling in from NFL Films the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience